all right now we head to the state of
new jersey where in the final hours
polls have now tightened within the
margin of error with republican
gubernatorial candidate jack citarelli
now is closing the gap against
democratic incumbent phil murphy and
promising to undo murphy's job-killing
tax hikes put a freeze on property taxes
reform education and make the state more
business friendly here to make his final
case republican gubernatorial candidate
jack citarelli is with us um you had
told me that your internal numbers were
or showed a tightening
uh robert cahalia will join us later
shows it's now within the margin of
error
uh i think this is probably even a
bigger surprise than maybe the
commonwealth of virginia
do you believe this is now within
striking distance
uh without a doubt sean internal polling
in both camps has it as a dead heat and
you know the history of new jersey
republicans have won six of the last 10
governor races and no incumbent
democratic governor has been reelected
in more than 40 years not jim florio not
jim mcgreevey not jon corzine and quite
frankly phil murphy is far left of all
three of those combined so we're right
where we need to be at this point in
time
one of the main issues the focus that
people are focused on there obviously
education just popped all over virginia
and it went viral it went national what
are the biggest bread and butter issues
from what i can see a lot of it is
covered mandates the nursing home
scandal that was the equivalent of what
happened in new york although governor
murphy seemed to get away with it more
than cuomo did
um and then the issue of oh if if you're
against uh my high taxes probably new
jersey is not your state
new jerseyans are the highest tax people
in the nation uh sean and this is a guy
who said he wanted to make new jersey
the california of the east coast but
then he topped that and poked his finger
right in the eye of new jersey when he
said if taxes are your issue we're
probably not your state i mean he poked
him right in the eye so we've talked all
about property taxes ours are the
highest in the nation and making new
jersey a better place to do business
particularly for small business year
over year over year new jersey is ranked
the worst place in the country in which
to do business we've also got a state
government that's bloated it's
inefficient and it's been corrupted by
special interests those are the three
main fiscal economic issues that i've
talked about all throughout this
campaign and it's resonated with new
jerseyans
well we're going to be watching new
jersey very very closely tomorrow it's a
big race and uh if virginia and new
jersey flip tomorrow wow i can't think
of what uh that will do to put the
democrats into a tailspin we wish you
all the best uh thanks so much for being
with us i'm steve ducey i'm brian
killman and i'm ainsley earhardt and
click here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis